[Musique]
dans sa demande j'ai pas fait partie de
celles et ceux qui croient que l'or peut
changer le monde moi personnellement
peut-être un peu naïvement en fait j'ai
longtemps cru que ça pouvait suffire
pour libérer la société d injustice que
vivaient les femmes les personnes en
situation de précarité les personnes en
situation d'itinérance les personnes
racisées lgbt qu autochtone donc j'ai
toujours eu un petit côté militant fleur
bleue super candide me tondre est vrai
que l'artiste reprenne son rôle
fondamental dans nos sociétés celui
d'être messagers du peuple mais changer
le monde s'est passé 5
j'sais pas si vous avez déjà réfléchi à
la question de la prise de parole dans
l'espace public
à qui appartiennent les voix qu'on
entend qui ôte du pouvoir d'agir si on
s'y attarde un peu on se rend compte que
ces personnes ne se ressemblent
énormément lyon pour la plupart le même
statut économique le même statut
académique puis comme artiste en fait je
me suis posé la question qu'est-ce qui
se passerait si on allait voir les
personnes qui vivent la marginalisation
sociale qui est confuse et valoriser ces
voix là est ce qu'on ferait pas avoir un
impact de transformation sociale fort
donc je suis allé dans les ruelles dans
les abribus au coin beaubien
saint-hubert aux valentins raconte
rencontrer du monde
puis écouté leurs récits de vie à partir
de syrie cela j'ai créé des performances
des installations vidéo des projets de
photos puis je me disais vraiment
qu'avec cela j'allais réussir à changer
le monde je parlais avec les projets on
parlait de pauvreté on parlait de
pression on parlait de violences
on parlait aussi de résistance ordinaire
j'ai présenté mon travail au québec à
l'étranger j'ai même représenté le
canada à la première exposition d'art
international féministe de roumanie donc
comment 6 le savez vraiment là
les super bien mon affaire mais il me
manquait vraiment quelque chose de
fondamental le vrai impact social j'y
arrivais pas donc je sais pas si vous
vous êtes déjà pris une claque
symbolique en pleine face le tic en
claquant d'apprendre que la réalité
rattrape mais le jour où skg rage est
réalisée en fait que présenter mon
travail dans des galeries dans les
événements dans des festivals devant des
publics super convaincu qu'ils
partageaient pour la plupart mes valeurs
ça changeait pas le monde bambins mais
je me suis pris une dose d'humilité
donc le je me suis relevé les manches et
demandé à nouveau comment leur peut
changer le monde pendant mon parcours
j'ai aussi étudié en pédagogie des
ordres je me suis intéressé en fait à la
transmission non hiérarchique des
savoirs artistique je me demandais
comment l'école pouvait être un lieu de
mise en commun de réflexion collective
ou est ce que les enseignants qui lie
les étudiants en fête pouvait à la fois
jouer le rôle d'enseignant et le rôle
d'apprenants j'avais jamais fait le lien
en fait entre ma démarche d'artiste puis
ma démarche pédagogique qui à un moment
donné ça mau comme frappés comme par
magie
je me suis dit mais oui mais si au lieu
de faire des oeuvres sur des personnes
marginalisées
je crée des oeuvres avec ces personnes
là dans une perspective de partage des
savoirs de collaboration de co
apprentissage donc le jour où est ce que
cette idée l'homme a frappé c'est ça le
vraiment changé en fait complètement ma
façon de voir leur fille juste l'idée de
l'or pour le changement social que je me
suis inspiré en fait d'un modèle elle
existait déjà qui était proposée par
l'organisme engrenage noir rouages et
qui ressemblait à si on y regarde de
plus près ce que l'organisme nous
propose est grosso modo c'était de
rassembler les membres d'un organisme
communautaire autour d'un projet commun
donc les membres de l'organisme on leur
donne un rôle un peu plus important
vraiment centrale dans le projet qui on
leur associe des artistes puis les
organismes mêmes qui sont représentés
par les intervenants et intervenantes
donc le premier projet qu'on a fait en
suivant le modèle de l'or communautaire
militants a été réalisée au centre
jeunesse de citer les prairies
donc le centre jeunesse de cité des
prairies c'est un lieu pour les jeunes
qui ont été judicieuse et puis notre
idée en fait peut-être créer un espace
de libre expression
ou est ce que ces jeunes là pourrait
prendre reprendre du pouvoir d'agir en
fait sur des situations des enjeux
sociopolitiques qui les touchait de près
donc est un amant les milieux nous a
ouvert la porte pipe mot faut dire que
on n'avait pas de l'art de venir
remettre en question l'ordre établi bain
avec non rouleaux de papier kraft nos
crayons de couleur ils nous ont laissé
faire et dans le fond on est on a débuté
avec des intervenants et intervenantes
super sceptiques
la première fois qu'on est allé là ils
nous ont dit ah ouais vous pouvez
essayer de leur faire parler de
politique à ces jeunes leur mais ils
s'en foutent dehors tout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est les shakespeare et
chats
c'est à partir de là on s'est dit ok -
peut-être que c'est un peu fou notre
idée mais pas pantoute
on a commencé à faire des ateliers mais
ça nous parlait de questions
philosophiques de responsabilité de
jugement moral
on n'arrivait vraiment en fait à avoir
des discussions super intéressant la
face et qu'on utilisait lors comme un
outil d'expression dont concret des
espaces avec l'or ou est ce que les
jeunes pouvaient parler s'exprimer
librement
mon niveau du résultat ça marchait pas
pantoute l'impact épaules la qualité
esthétique conceptuel et est pas là on
avait un super processus éthique
les jeunes nous donnait vraiment du
contenu mais on n'arrivait pas pantoute
à avoir un modèle qui fait de l'heure
pour le changement social
donc ça nous prenait un modèle amélioré
j'avais essayé de voir des oeuvres sur
les personnes qui vivre de l'exclusion
sociale j'avais essayé de faire de l'or
avec les personnes à l'intérieur d'un
modèle d'art comme nota militants ça
fonctionnait pas non plus faites-le vous
devez vous poser la question à note une
recette miracle
comment qui a fini par y arriver ben oui
puis à s'appelle recette miracle donc on
aurait équilibrer les rapports entre les
artistes les intervenants pis les
participants on a reconnu qu'on avait
tous des savoirs spécifiques et
complémentaires qu'on pourrait mettre au
service d'un projet commun on a revu les
rôles de chacun une manière de
travailler
on a identifié nos priorités on ensuite
développé ni sera un modèle de stratégie
d'impact on a clarifié nos processus
on a inclus la rétroaction dans nos
actions puis la stratégie de diffusion
dans le projet avec les jeunes
bref on s'est converti au design
thinking on a fait des beaux schémas
pour présenter ce qu'on faisait plus moi
mais je me soumets mettre des vêtements
donc le premier schéma présente de la
façon dont on va travailler autour du
projet commun donc tu vas y avoir les
participants participantes qui eux elles
ont un savoir expérientiel super fort
dans leur vie vont être confrontés à des
problématiques puis sont devenus
spécialistes en fait de ces problèmes là
qu'ils ont plein d'idées sur comment
qu'on peut régler les problèmes mais
dans le fond on veut mobiliser ce savoir
expérientiel là autour du projet comme
il ya aussi les intervenants et
intervenantes qui ont un savoir du
terrain institutionnel dont qui ont la
capacité à animer le groupe a validé que
tout le monde se sent bien tout seuls
mais ils ont aussi d'autres
connaissances
ils connaissent les rouages de leur
milieu ils connaissent les acteurs
actrices d' influence
ils savent c'est quoi qui a été testé
dans le passé qui marchent pas pourquoi
tu es que dans le fond sont le pour eux
ils sont là pour accompagner la
réflexion critique du groupe pour
s'assurer que tout le monde veut
vraiment savoir comme va vraiment
réfléchir en fait à comment atteindre
cet objectif le les artistes
une fois qu'on est libéré nos petits
malaises de prendre trop de place dans
la rencontre
enfin donné lieu pour partager notre
savoir esthétique puis conceptuel
c'est vrai que dans la vie de tout le
monde un sensibilité artistique je vais
pas nier ce mais c'était difficile pour
nous d'assumer pleinement de prendre le
rôle de dire nous on en a un savoir
esthétique plus conceptuel on a étudié à
l'université pour se on a fait de la
pratique artistique salle une valeur
fait qu au lieu d'être gênée on s'est
dit non on veut mais on veut mettre tous
ceux au service du projet commun parce
que nous on ne se savoir le spécifique
par la suite on a fait un deuxième
schéma celui là il est un peu plus
simple dans le fond on a pris notre
schéma triangulaire de projets communs
penser dit il faut faire reposer sur
trois piliers d'action des choses qui
par le passé on s'était rendu compte
qu'on avait laissés pour compte des fois
un peu le processus des fois un peu la
forme des fois un peu le contenu des
fois un petit peu l'impact fait classer
dit non non il faut assumer ce qu'on
veut c'est une qualité esthétique
conceptuel forte un processus éthique
irréprochable puis un impact social
concret avec notre schéma mais on s'en
sert dans les ateliers vont seuls ramène
toujours en tête pour s'assurer que tout
le monde est sur la même longueur d'onde
que vraiment on travaille
équilibre en fait donc en fait notre
troisième schéma lui qui est un petit
peu plus complexe on a travaillé avec
notre équipe à se poser la question au
bout de six ans de faire des gens
d'ateliers comme ce finalement c'est
quoi un processus de co création
on est arrivé à le simplifier dans un
modèle en 10 points 10 points c'est
beaucoup
vous avez aussi pas si compliqué que le
mais j'ai choisi pour vous partagez
notre processus de vous l'ancré dans le
dernier projet qu'on a fait notre
dernière réalisation ça s'appelle 310
c'est un projet de réalité virtuelle
documentaire qui étaient réalisés avec
des jeunes filles placées au centre
jeunesse de laval donc au départ la
première étape c'est qu'on veut
apprendre à se connaître
puis à créer un lien de confiance ça
peut avoir l'air vraiment niaiseux mais
dans le fond on travaille dans des
milieux où est ce que les gens sont
habitués de voir des interviews le temps
que tu sois en centre jeunesse que tu
sois dans un organisme communautaire
les gens sont toujours entouré
d'intervenants putois bain avec ton
petit l'ucl d'entrepreneur social bête
au delà de l'intervenant sexy on veut
mettre des rapports de travail non
hiérarchique
il faut comme casser ce site en partant
de la façon dont se prend c'est vraiment
de venir raconter notre vécu dire d'où
est ce qu'on vient qui d'aller à la
rencontre de ces personnes ne crée un
espace sécuritaire ou est ce que tout le
monde se sent libre de s'exprimer
par la suite on va partager nos attentes
pineau besoins respectifs
c'est aussi sa faveur de la nièvre mais
avec l'expérience on s'est rendu compte
qu'ils ont été honnêtes sur ce à quoi on
aspire et comme artiste ce à quoi on
aspirait comme militants militantes puis
que les jeunes les participants
participantes était un être pourquoi il
était là dans ses activités le on avait
de meilleures idées de ou est ce qu'on
voulait aller ensemble on s'organisait
pour y aller ensuite on passe par les
activités de libre expression
donc ça c'est un espace en fait tout est
ce que tout le monde on peut partager
notre vécu ça peut prendre plein de
forme des textes des projets photos des
projets vidéo
l'important c'est que le brûle de notre
réussite vie sorte qu'ils qu'on puisse
l'analyser après en gagne donc cette
activité le nous permet par la suite de
cibler une problématique commune dans le
code nos filles
à laval le projet en fait était la
problématique était de parler des
décalages vécu entre une adolescente est
institutionnalisée pis la vraie vie elle
avait à 18 ans qu'ils allaient allait
sortir en fait du centre jeunesse et se
sentent est très anxieuse je peux
nécessairement prep à ceux qui en examen
on va adresser les décalages parce que
c'est à l'intérieur de l'institution on
pouvait mieux comprendre c'est quoi
l'impact de ces décalages le peut-être
que les règles seraient différentes
donc pour analyser la problématique
notre intervenante accompagnatrice
stéphanie nous a vraiment aidé à
comprendre cette équipe prenait les
décisions techniques étaient derrière
les programmes centre jeunesse c'est
qu'ils avaient un pouvoir d'âge et si on
disait ben nous c'est seul problème
qu'on veut régler tout acquis qu'on
s'adresse donc grâce à son travail que
vraiment stimuler la réflexion critique
du groupe
on a ciblé des objectifs de
transformation puis un public cible
notre premier public cible ça se
trouvait à être les cadres de
l'institution qui eux avaient un pouvoir
dire et d'action par la suite on va se
demander comment on peut faire ça
artistiquement donc dans le cadre dans
le cas des filles de 310 elles sont
arrivées elles ont des mauges et c'est
ce qu'on va faire on va créer une bois
une grosse boîte noire se roule est que
là on va enfermer le spectateur de dans
ce cas là comme ceux ayant peu choix
nous écoutent et puis on va y projeter
des images de notre chambre de notre
unité pour y parler on va dire comme ça
va sentir c'est quoi ça fait d'être dans
nos studios fécamp l'élimination à
rimouski magnifique c'est que on le sait
tout le monde en même temps les artistes
les intervenants les participants
participantes ça fait comme élimination
huawei c'est vraiment fort ben oui on
devrait faire ça après on s'embarque
dans la réalisation concrète de l'oeuvre
le de notre boîte à roulettes qui devait
aller au palais de justice d'un centre
d'achat puis se promener à brossard on
s'est retrouvé avec une oeuvre de
réalité virtuelle donc ont amené la
chambre l'unité
la cuisine la cour dans un univers 360
avec le récit des filles pour s'assurer
qu'on va arriver à notre objectif avec
notre oeuvre pendant le processus de
création on va faire des retrouve action
constante avec le milieu donc idéalement
on va aller voir notre public cible
qu'on va vouloir choquer par la suite on
va les tester bord ça marche si notre
approche est fonctionnel qui conduit le
par la suite avec le groupe on va
déterminer un plan de diffusion
donc comment on veut que cette oeuvre
devient un levier de transformation
concret par la suite à l'intérieur puis
à l'extérieur du milieu
donc là je vous ai fait une présentation
très dense de notre façon de travailler
puis vraiment là j'ai fait un gros gros
travail procédure simplifiée mais je me
suis dit la meilleure façon d'en parler
ça nous fait revivre un petit quelque
chose je vais vous demander de regarder
l'image qui derrière moi la regarder un
instant puis de vous la mettre en tête
parce que je vais vous demander de vous
fermer les yeux puis d'écouter en fait
la parole de nos jeunes filles donc on
est dans cette image
dans la vraie chambre d'une jeune fille
de centres jeunesse qui passent
plusieurs heures par jour à réfléchir
donc m voici ce qu'est la vie partagé
trois heures à 4 heures changement de
corps une heure de travail sur toi c'est
l'on ferme les yeux se voit quoi à quoi
tu penses
moi je pense à ma famille parce que
j'aurais dû faire pour poety si je pense
à la vie qui continue sans moi à
l'extérieur au moment que je manque avec
les gens que j'aime le temps avance trop
vite quand je suis retourné à la maison
la dernière fois c'était bizarre ma mère
avait comme vieilli d'un coup ça
marchait difficilement à l'avait mal
partout
j'ai essayé de me coucher avec elle
comme quand j'étais petit mais j'avais
comme plus comme un à prendre dans mes
bras à force de ne pas avoir le droit de
contact physique tu fini par oublier
même avec mon chum c'est quand
je les prends pas la main je le colle
pas il trouve que je suis hors ce que tu
penses que je vais savoir comment mes
limites avec les autres une fois dans
vraie vie commence à voir le genre de
contacts qui sont bons pour moi ce
qu'ils sont ce que je vais rester
sauvage le même tu penses
je sais pas si vous pouvez imaginer
l'impact cohue 310 sur le milieu mais de
voir des cadres ont des directeurs
directrices des intervenants et
intervenantes plonger dans l'univers des
filles dans leurs mots comprendre les
impacts de leur travail de leur vie il y
avait même même lorsqu'on a fait de la
première présentation
la grande grande break preuve des
centres jeunesse ces gens de madame
super politically correct là que ces
textes sont écrits par quelqu'un d'autre
qu'à bien les lire en public qui d'avoir
vu la madame pousser son texte sur son
le train qui de regarder les faits d'un
tout petit les filles merci pour votre
courage avant aujourd'hui le je me
levais à tout les matin j'étais vraiment
convaincu que je faisais là meilleur job
du monde
puis vous venez me prouver que non qu'il
ya encore du travail à faire que je
m'engage vraiment à le faire avec vous
ce travail ce qui aurait pu avoir l'air
de des paroles de politiciens
ça c'est vraiment concrétisé en ce
moment au centre jeunesse de laval il ya
des comités de travail qui se sont basés
sur notre scénario pour analyser les
services chacune des 13 5 qui dénonce
quelque chose qu'il a des comités de
travail en actions pour se dire
effectivement ça le aucun sens qu'est ce
qu'elles vivent ses fils
ce soir là pour de vrai les filles ma
collègue les intervenants et
intervenantes ont cédé écoute
waouh on a vraiment fait quelque chose
de grand grâce à la prise de parole des
filles à leur réflexion critique alors
on avait changé le monde un plus ce jour
là
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]